[Music]
alright don't confuse the training
paradigm with an application paradigm so
here here I'm letting his joke come to
full fruition so the line of attack is
physically manifested understand so
that's telling me given me a visual cue
of where that is where the parry happens
the line of the parry okay the
application cannot be your turn my turn
he's not gonna be there the application
is I need him as he's hitting me but
that's the line I take okay so he has to
wake up on his you Kimmy
[Music]
you
so as as you move from your kilo on and
you're trying to bridge the gap you're
trying to get out and shoot you're
trying to get into pop you have to
understand the original keyhole
narrative better so right now you guys
have like this kind of long it's not
like that so we're trying to fight each
other I think you see I was on the 12:6
line in your mind you're stuck on the 12
see I already moved this way move to get
it it's very much like right here and
he's gonna throw his reverse punch and
I'm like this no right
he goes look I'm already off
[Music]
so this is an application right time to
shield my body do you got it this is not
it
I'm over here so I go here and as he
starts pulip I'm adopted that posture
did you get it and so once I adopted
that posture the question is how will
what can I do it well we're gonna come
over the top do you see that so that
this is what happens when you'll get
there's that pause and it's the wrong
mindset right you're here like this wait
I'm already hitting it over the top do
you see that difference okay so we're
just gonna work on on this it's a little
bit we wanted a little bit more dynamic
so start to deconstruct this twelve six
line that you got in your subconscious
and instead you're working with him what
it and I'm over here boom
no more like this all right let's go
okay so let's go back to the to the
training paradigm so he goes and I have
the manifestation of the line of attack
and look how my end of my Joe is on the
other side of the line of attack do you
see that okay I don't want it on the
other side what I'm doing is bringing it
slowly this way and but I'm doing it
with a propeller like a fence you see do
you guys see that
Thanks so as he goes with my manifest
his line of attack you're gonna watch
the tip come over to this side you see
how it's doing that
boom so as this is happening on that
line of attack that is all a parrying
like motion so as we go to the
application I don't want to go I don't
want to go like this because I didn't do
that I was on the other side let's go
back to manifestation and I'm here and I
went like this do you see that I don't
want to do that but at the same time I'm
not going here I want that propeller
parry so I'm here oh I want that over
here as much as possible
[Music]
okay try it again just like so the
concept is not his turn my turn to get
it it's just it's just like the knife
drill it is imagine your husband I'd
right go who you cutting that thing the
thing that's coming out the target that
is close to you you're heading it he
committed he stuck his hand out in the
middle of no man's land and I'm knocking
it I'm late
think about that stop thinking about
attacking me do you understand that you
guys get that process so now he's
defending himself do you got it I
supposed to hear him just gonna pull
that joke back go and ski again instead
right boom I'm hitting it the next
strategic element is I want to reduce
his mobility so that's where the otoshi
comes in keeping the Joe lie I'm
checking his height you see that just
temporarily so that when I come in to
ski I can get him so the way to do this
safely is you want that foot will go
slow so you can see it he goes I've hit
boom I'm on my foot if I can get my foot
in this four inches then I know I see
them you get it so pay attention to my
foot do you guys see that
let's go same kind of beginner
misunderstanding so as you're coming
around here you have like that I gotta
touch the bottom of this Joe no you
don't okay second misunderstanding is
I'm trying to ski as fast as I can't see
you don't want to drop your weight is
that's gonna take some time to get up
you see that
you start doing a weak acid push your
hair like that but he can't move can you
all he had to do is move his hand when
he saw my weapon coming around and he's
still on the fight so I have to actually
again in the same way that I deal with
that you see he pulled the hand off the
weapon heat up with that he's not
attacking me now so the same thing here
I have to go me then I can come in do
you guys understand so to reiterate the
drill keeping her trying to get out of
it and I'm gonna try to put my foot as
close to him as possible and that's
gonna require that I check
I'm just not throwing this ski for
safety sake
please okay let's go
all right so neck next application
principle so I follow my hit I checked
it's doll delay right take away his
mobility and I close the gap now flute
when I do the ski don't get stuck in
format don't go all I need is the area
between him and I now clear you
understand that's all I need
so backing application
or I'm sorry kion I'm here to see his
weapon is still there his weapon is
still there
his weapon is still there so I have to
come off his weapon do you see that
because if I go to ski down parameter
you see but when I start to do it more
application but overwrite his weapons
not there I'm already off only draw the
weapon back as much as you need to not
have his weapon on the centerline so if
you get away with that right this do it
if you need to come all the way over
here do it I love it
I fill the gap as soon as it's open it
will be open foam on the Atocha
you fill that gap immediately with you
ad me and your scheme go soon
not everything is technical alright so
when I'm here you go I have to have the
skill of being able to read his body
plus is in tension here it comes I know
now yeah yeah you guys are not doing
that you are never going to bridge the
gap from key home to application because
this skills missing this skill is
assumed in the key bond and because you
don't have that this is always late you
see that or you want it it's late so you
shortchange it
yeah you're gonna do whatever you want
when you have that skill so body reading
[Music]
so watch how is his hand get said that's
where my Jo is we're there together you
got it
okay so pull this dude you he'll mix it
up okay he doesn't call it written this
this one I've seen him do he gets her
rhythm he mixes it up oh oh that means
you're gonna go sometimes late sometimes
slow right I just read him do I not do
anything
get some snappy attention
trying to kill me